So, you guys have to come on to this set and stand the institute set up and institute set
up you have the template reference right and template preferences we have this dynamic builder
report builder and the other one is the PDF template okay so PDF template okay so there
could be ID card there could be a lower certificate there could be one of our certificate admission
received okay it could be event it could be nodius certificate it could be admit card it could be
student's right so when you click then you have this option to add the multiple of the
templates okay is that okay so what i was saying is for example i have to create a fee receipt
right so what i will do is i'll select the fee receipt give it a name for example fee receipt
start okay then you have the count as well the
if you select the one the same then it will be a single receipt if you select two with horizontal
then two print only in horizontal and then you have the two as vertical vertical make over
then one just below the other right and then four is the four divide four
and then you have the courses courses is what like
class one class two
now there could be chances that a certificate can be different for
respective classes right the class one or two
let me go with the college one apart
so let's go with the school and right school of engineering school of computer applications
school of political science
right then you can do one thing
as you click
you can select the default template which are available at the back end right
you can get the preview as well
me
there could be changes in the alignment there could be changes in the you know
okay
you will give it to you right then you will select a particular template because the reason
is that the template you have selected here, for example, if you have selected a free receipt
and put the code of bona fide certificate in it, then when you will print the free receipt,
then there is a bona fide certificate.
for example, you have selected a free receipt and here you have to do one thing,
you have to give the template and after that you have to select the free receipt,
and in the case of free receipt, you have to keep the same template and put the name of the free receipt.
Now tell me one thing, what is this certificate, bona fide certificate?
Which template have you selected?
The one I have selected in the report, that is the free receipt.
As soon as I add it and print it,
now what I have done, I have made a free receipt template,
one template was already existing,
and I have created one template, that is the default template.
Now when I will go to the default template and go to the transaction list and print the free receipt of anyone,
then what do you think, what should be the print?
Will it be a free receipt or a bona fide certificate?
How much is the bona fide one?
It should be printed.
Which one should be printed?
Error message.
Okay, tell me more.
What I have done is, I have selected the template, your free receipt,
I have put the code, bona fide,
now what will be the print?
The template of bona fide will be printed.
Exactly, so bona fide will be printed.
So I have printed the free receipt from here,
what did it print?
It printed a bona fide certificate.
But notice one thing,
only in those variables,
the variables that we have given in the bona fide certificate,
if we have given its free heights,
if we have given its amount,
how much is collected,
then that will also be printed.
The bona fide certificate is also printed inside.
So always remember one thing,
on which particular trigger,
the particular template attached to you,
that will be printed.
Now no matter what code you put in it,
whatever code you put, it will be printed.
You think that I have created a free receipt,
then the receipt will be printed.
It is not like that.
You have to check the code.
Now I will show you one thing.
This was the old receipt.
Now what is in its preview?
This is the preview of the old receipt.
Now I will turn on the default,
and the new one that we made,
we will turn off the default.
Because the preview of this is our bona fide certificate.
And that is that.
Then coming on to the transaction list.
What else should be printed?
Transaction receipt.
Preview receipt.
Preview receipt, right?
Transaction fees, previous fees,
that will come.
Now simply my point to clear here,
that is that,
whatever template you select,
it will not matter.
That is only for that thing.
What is your trigger?
Now if you have written Govind in the code,
then Govind will be printed.
You have written Rinky, Kunal,
whatever you write,
it will be printed.
The reports that we are selecting,
these are for the triggers.
Because in the fee receipt,
there are two particular templates.
One is default,
if you default both,
then whatever you get, it will be printed.
But what we do,
it will depend on whether
you have made it separate for each class,
otherwise our single receipt is the clue.
We will delete it now.
And here whatever count is coming,
with this you will be able to clear it.
There are 8 report cards,
10 admit card templates,
1 employee card template,
1 event template, 1 admission form,
fee receipt, no-due certificate,
de-replication certificate, library receipt,
student ID card,
character certificate,
multiple certificates.
Sir, in the count,
how many types of templates are saved?
Yes, for example,
if I click on character certificate,
character certificates are 7 there,
and each one is separate for the school.
Sundarbeeth is separate for BHNT,
Sundarbeeth is separate for law,
Sundarbeeth is separate for engineering,
Sundarbeeth is separate for management,
we have given different names.
And we have also selected the same schools.
The one that needs to be printed,
I will show you there.
And we will default it.
Make sure whenever you make a template,
first you will check
what is your requirement.
According to that requirement,
if you feel that my existing template,
look, in most of the cases,
the template that comes by default,
like you select load template,
for example, I don't do admission transaction,
I click on character certificate.
As soon as I click on load,
the code that I have on the back end
will come up as it is.
In most of the cases,
you have to change the code a little bit.
I am not telling you the part
where you have to change the code.
But you have to change the code here.
For example, if they tell you
that your character certificate
should be printed in the upper case.
What is the character certificate
that you are writing?
This is the character certificate.
Apply styling to it.
Write the upper case directly from here.
Either write it directly,
then it will be printed in the upper case.
You don't have to do it like this.
As it was before,
you can apply styling to the div,
or you can apply styling to the span,
or you can apply styling to the x-transform.
Like this.
Then it will be printed in the upper case.
This is the basic thing.
I am not going too much into it.
The main thing is that
you should understand
from where the template is being printed
and what is the meaning of which variable.
For example,
I will give you a variable here.
DisplayData.EntityName
EntityName is what?
EntityName is the name of the institute.
Like SDJI, like RMPG College,
Pipe College.
This is the name of the entity.
Then you have the
DisplayData.EntityAddress
This is the address of the entity.
This is the state of the entity.
This is the country.
Then you have the pin code.
There are multiple variables over here.
For example,
the gender of the student as well.
The name of the student.
You can say
the father name of the student.
Do you understand, guys?
What do you want to say?
Yes, sir.
This is how you have to create a template.
By default, you have to select
in most of the cases.
Your report card is also your default.
In most of the schools,
if you don't have a high level school
or advanced school,
the default report card has to work.
They don't have the requirement
to do something like a high end.
But for some special schools,
you have to make changes.
So what I was saying is
this is the default toggle.
This is your default toggle
which you have to turn on and off.
If you don't know how to do it,
I have activated or inactivated this code.
You have created a template.
If you turn on the default as on,
that one will be printed.
If you turn it off,
the one before this will be printed.
And if there is no one existing,
then it will be printed
on the back end.
Yes, sir.
Sir, there was an issue.
When I was making it,
let me show you something on the screen.
Sir, let me show you something.
What was it?
Sir, here it is coming in this way.
Use default.
And I don't think
it is in the content shortage.
No.
But if you don't see
the load template here,
if you click on use default,
then something comes up.
Yes, yes.
It is possible that it is not in the load template.
It may be on the default button.
Your buttons were not coming.
What I was saying is
if your template is not in the system,
then it will be printed on the back end.
If it is in your system,
then it will be printed on the system.
The condition is
it should be defaulted on.
Am I clear?
Divya, Rinki, Kunal, Govind?
Yes, sir.
Okay.
So, this was basic.
In the template,
you have to add where you want to come.
What is the meaning of default?
If I have to make different classes for different classes,
then how can I make them?
Okay?
Sir.
Sir, when we will make it,
will the set default button be on?
Yes, the set default button is on.
Okay, sir.
Basically, in most of the cases,
if you get proper expression entity,
then in that case, all the side defaults are there.
But in some cases,
there are some ID cards,
for example, there are nine ID cards.
Right?
In the case of that ID card,
there are different ID cards of different schools.
So, you have to allow different defaults.
Okay?
Sir, tell me once, why do we do set default?
Once.
We do set default so that the code is printed.
That means we activate it.
Okay.
So that the template is active and inactive.
If you turn off the default,
it will become inactive.
If you turn it on, it will become active.
Okay, let's say there is a student ID card,
and I have set all the defaults on it,
like here.
And I have also ticked all the classes.
So, if I go and print
a student ID card,
let's say,
then what will be the print?
Then it will get the first.
Okay.
It will print the first in the series.
The code works like this, right?
If your condition is true in the code,
as soon as the condition is true,
your code is executed.
Okay.
So, this was the basic thing.
Remember one thing,
in the template, for example,
I have printed this for you.
Sometimes,
when you are working,
you don't get the variables.
Okay, you printed it,
the student's name was not printed,
for example, the category was not printed.
Right?
Now, there could be chances
that the variable you have set
will have some issue.
Okay?
So, what will you do?
You will have to inspect the page,
right click,
and then this inspect.
Is the screen showing up?
It is showing up.
So, once you click on the inspect,
then you have to come on to the console.
Okay? In console, you have the object.
Object is what brings your data.
Okay?
So, as soon as I opened the object,
all my variables came here.
Student's name, student's father's name,
student's mobile number,
student's age number, student's role number,
what is the section, what is the stream,
what is the total demand,
how much amount it has paid, right?
How much amount it has paid,
how much is in the words, right?
How much more amount it had to pay, right?
The name of the person who printed it.
Okay? Clear?
Yes.
Okay, now what I was saying is
that the student's category was not printed.
Okay, for example, you have to enter the category.
There is no such category.
Right? The category is coming here.
Okay?
Yes, sir.
Okay, now the category is coming here,
but it is not coming here.
It could be possible that the variable
that we have used there
is wrong.
For example, I have viewed the code here.
Well,
I will come on to the
student's role number, student's category.
Right? Okay, now look at one thing.
What variable did I use? Student's category.
But what is the real variable?
Category, sir.
Right? Clear?
Yes, sir.
There could be multiple
templates where the student's category
is written and the value is being passed
in the variable. But there are some
templates where the category is written.
For example, I will tell you
what happens sometimes. There is a student's name.
We have the student's name.
We have the student's father's name.
It is completely written. Student's father's name.
There are some templates where
instead of the student's father's name,
there is only the student's father's name.
So if you call the student's father's name there,
the value doesn't come in the variable.
Right?
For example, right now my category is wrong.
So what I will do is copy the category
from here and paste it.
Okay? DisplayData.
This will always be there.
It will always be there before the variable.
Okay? DisplayData is our array that
will call the data and bring it.
For this category,
DisplayData.student will call the value
for the reg number. Right?
For example, I have made changes.
I will edit this.
I don't have to edit it. I will reprint it.
Okay?
Right?
Did you understand how to take it out?
Okay?
Now there is one more thing.
You will not get
a simple object.
There will be no variable.
For example, you have to print the school's logo.
So DisplayData.logo will come.
You have to print the old new.
So you put the old new directly.
You have to print the session.
Because sometimes it comes like this.
The institute says to print the session
on our fee receipt.
So what we do is, I think the session will be based
on this.
So this is our session.
So what we will do is, like the category
below, we will make another div.
In that div, we will pass the session with the variable.
Okay?
Is that clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
And right now, I was directly talking
about every object.
But sometimes, your object is inside the array.
Okay?
Objects inside the array, like for columns,
position, fee head, installment,
and simply
for fee head groups.
So it's an array.
So there's a list of remarks.
Then there's an array.
How to call an array,
that's the help of the loop.
I'll tell you that later.
For now, just understand, if my variable is not being printed,
I have to look at it.
Okay?
Okay, guys?
Yes, sir.
Okay?
I will take more time.
I have to print a report card.
I have to do a stress test.
After this, I will give you a template
and you can try it.
So, in this session,
there will be
a report card.
I will show you the results.
Then I have to report card.
I will click on to the terms.
This is the trigger.
You have to print a report card.
Sumaya, I will tell you one thing.
You have made multiple report cards there.
Okay?
Here, the listing is like this.
If you make five report cards
it will not print by default.
It will ask you which one to print.
In some cases,
you have made five or seven different templates.
It doesn't ask there.
For example, fee receipts,
bona fide certificate,
student feedback,
appreciation certificate,
character certificate,
you don't get such listings there.
You can directly print there.
As soon as you click on the print, it will print.
But in the case of report card,
it asks you properly.
For example, I had to print class 1 and 2.
So, this is the report card
which is not printed.
Okay?
Action report.
This is how the report card is printed.
Each school's report card
can be different.
This is the school's report card.
For you, I will show you one more.
There is a report card.
I mean, nursery.
Okay?
So, I am telling you the requirement of the school.
This is the report card
of pre-nursery.
Okay.
And this is not available
at the default school.
This is a customized report card.
Data is being dynamically called.
But the designing and everything
is customized.
So, I am making it clear.
There are many schools who need
such report cards.
So, you have to tell me.
Okay?
The date is coming.
Table is coming. Everything is coming.
And I have made the table.
Thank you.
So, there is one
institute.
I will show you that.
I will show you the character setting.
I am understanding
little by little what I am saying.
How the data is coming.
Okay?
The console I showed you earlier
was very easy to understand.
But the console on the report card
is very complex.
Okay? There is an array.
In that array, you have multiple of the variables.
Okay?
Now, in this,
what is the group?
What is the skill group? What is inside it?
What are the subjects?
What is the assessment group? What is inside the assessment group?
Then, you will get the values.
Are you watching?
Okay?
Do you understand what I am saying?
Divya, Kunal,
Govind, Ranki.
Little by little.
So, what I was saying is
when we go to the report card,
the report card,
the report card has a different concept.
We will take it separately.
The console we need to read,
we will do it separately.
We are leaving it for now.
But it is a little complex report card.
The rest is easy.
I just showed you a character certificate.
The character was bona fide.
Now, I will show you the template
of the character certificate.
It is simple.
This is the character certificate.
Okay?
This is the default one.
Okay, guys?
Why is it bona fide?
The bona fide certificate,
it is used for something.
I don't have much knowledge about it.
It is used for legal work.
It is used for school work.
The bona fide is used
to show that the student is
studying in this particular college or school.
Okay.
So, this is the code
that we got.
That was the default code.
Now, I will show you the character certificate.
Sir, please show us the transfer certificate.
See,
this is also a character certificate
and this is also a character certificate.
That is the second template, right?
No, it is not the second template.
It is designed custom.
Okay.
Let me check.
See,
it is a proper custom designed template.
So, this is also
a character certificate?
Yes.
It is fully coded.
Okay.
And the stamp is also coded.
Sir, I wanted to ask
if this stamp is also coded?
Yes, it is coded.
Yes, I understand.
Okay.
I think this is not coded.
Okay. This is not coded.
Otherwise, we will select it.
This could be
a direct image
or something.
Yes, it is an image.
If it was not an image,
it would have been clear.
Okay.
So, that is the image.
But yes, you can code it
because there is not much space in it.
If you put a rotate on it,
it will look like a stamp.
Okay.
So, there are also custom templates
which you have to design.
Now, if you want to check the same values
then you will come here and open the console.
Sometimes,
as I was telling you,
I will show you one thing.
Character certificate and institute certificate.
Where is the character certificate?
Okay.
Now, look at one thing.
Here, the character certificate is increasing a little.
But when we print here,
it does not come on the full screen.
Okay. So, because of this,
when you make anything,
the preview is not final.
You can check the design.
You can check how it looks.
You can check if the code is breaking.
Okay, I will show you how the code breaks.
For example, if you have started a div,
or if you have started a section,
you have to remove the code from this section.
Okay.
For example, I have removed the code.
Now, if I preview it,
it is not printed.
It means that one of my particular
is not closed.
Do you understand?
It means that the action will not be performed.
Oh, yes.
For example, if I used to throw an error,
I have to do this.
If you have started a div,
or if you have started something in a template,
after it comes to you,
when you remove the code from here,
or if you leave it at that time,
it will not be previewed.
This will tell you that my code is broken.
Is that okay, guys?
Yes.
Okay.
Yes, sir.
Sir, once the transfer certificate
is not being opened,
you are saying that
this is what you were asking.
Transfer certificate?
No, not from here.
From the student's pay certificate.
Since when is the transfer certificate?
Because every certificate has a different name.
Have you ever done a transfer certificate
in this?
I think
I have.
Certificates.
Okay.
You can also rename the certificate,
if you want.
Here is the TC certificate, right?
What is coming here?
College living certificate.
Student ledger is coming here.
Here is the student ledger.
Okay.
You can also rename this certificate.
Your pay certificate,
I will turn off the recording.
Thank you.